l'atelier a continué de fonctionner
malgré le confinement situe à coignières
la pme automation 2000 fabrique des
produits pour les transformateurs
électriques en respectant les normes
sanitaires les collaborateurs ont
continué l'activité jusqu'à la fin du
mois de mars
la baisse du chiffre d'affaires au mois
de mars tout simplement parce qu'elle va
justement on a dû envoyer des commandes
qui étaient prévus pour le web des
frileux pour le moment on a géré
vraiment je dirai tout car les commandes
de ce qui était prévu au chien est
quasiment tous partis menacent ni plus
ni moins depuis le début du mois d'avril
les commandes baissent l'activité
ralentit plusieurs employés sont placés
en activité partielle et du reste des
chansons qui sont encore là on est
capable de passer à la fabrication pour
répondre à des commandes ponctuelles ou
pour mettre en état du coi pas très
nette à faire les réglages qui vont bien
sûr des appareils qu'on a des gens
disons pour l'instant on n'est pas en
situation critique et du coup on essaie
de participer à l'effort française
dédiée aux antilles ont payé en charge
en remportant aucune échange le scandale
en payant fournisseurs et acheteurs mais
aussi que nos clients jouent pour la
plupart le jeu sur le thème des pays
aussi leur échéance au mois d'avril le
dirigeant de cette entreprise estime au
moins 50 % de perte de son activité en
2010 neuf il avait connu une baisse
d'environ 12% en raison de la
conjoncture économique dans ce secteur